Jordan,
great to chat with you today.
Hey,
thanks for the invitation.
Yeah.
As we were saying,
just before we started,
it's nice to finally
see you and talk to you.
We've been in touch for a
while and published a paper
on creativity and I should
give you even further context,
which I never gave you when we
were actually collaborating,
which is as I was working
on my dissertation,
I drove a lot on your work.
I drew a lot on your work on creativity
and personality and I thought there'd be
no better place than to
start with our discussion.
Then some of that seminal work you have
done on creativity and one concept that
really fascinated me in Grad school
was the idea of latent inhibition
and
you had done some work on that and
had found this really interesting link
between latent inhibition
and the personality trait,
openness to experience,
and then you did this,
you did that with Shelly Carson and
then you did this work linking it to
creative achievement.
So you could talk a little about what
is leading the mission and and how is it
related to creativity?
Well,
a lot of what we learn,
you know,
you might think that you
learn what things mean.
Okay,
and there is some truth in that,
but it's more accurate.
Many ways to reverse that,
like reversing so many things
in psychology is useful.
It's not that useful to try to
figure out why people get addicted,
for example.
It's very useful to figure
out why some people,
but most people aren't
addicted all the time.
It's not that difficult to
figure out why people are afraid.
What's hard is to understand why
people aren't afraid all the time.
So a lot of things in psychology,
we get backwards and we tend to think
that we learned the meaning of things,
but that's not exactly true.
It's more reasonable to point out that
we learned that things are irrelevant,
they start out meaningful and we learned
that there were irrelevant and the
reason for that is that when
you first encountered something,
you don't want to assume that it's
irrelevant mostly because it might be
dangerous.
Partly also because it might be useful,
but most of the things that we encounter,
proof neither be dangerous nor useful
and so that we can safely put them aside
with all the other things that we don't
attend to and we don't attend to almost
everything,
so learned irrelevance is unbelievably
important and latent inhibition is in
some sense a way of measuring how fast
someone can make something irrelevant
through learning.
So imagine that something surprises
you and you have a big response to it,
but nothing comes of it and
then the next time it pops up,
it doesn't surprise you at all.
That's basically learning
through latent inhibition.
Now,
one of the things we
started to contemplate,
this was back 20 years
ago with my student,
Shelly Carson and Daniel Higgins,
was the role that artists play
in revivifying perception.
So if you look at a van
Gogh painting of viruses,
for example,
or sunflowers,
very famous paintings as if the artist
makes you recall how those remarkable
phenomena manifest themselves so that
you can see them as if you're seeing them
again for the first time.
And what we thought was that perhaps
what the artist was doing was stripping
away your latent inhibition so that you
could see things the way you saw them
the first time in all their splendor
and glory before you pack them away
conceptually as irrelevant.
And so we tested that with creative
people and found that creative people did
have lower latent inhibition and sorted
people high in the personality trait.
Openness.
I love that.
I should say that hands.
Isaac got there first.
Curses soul.
It got everywhere.
He did.
William James Williams
has got everywhere for us,
but he,
in terms of personality,
I think got their first yet.
Well will you?
It's funny,
I guess in some sense William James
even got there before Isaac because he
played around with nitrous oxide,
right?
So he was one.
He was one of the first experiment
centers with hallucinogens fundamentally.
And he wrote hippie
poetry on nitric oxide,
noting what was likely something like the
stripping away of latent inhibition as
a consequence of,
of hallucinogenic use.
So yeah,
and we're all the eldest Huxley of course,
to believe that hallucinogens
in particular clean the
doors of perception using
William Blake's terminology so that it
was possible to see everything as if you
were seeing it for the first time.
There's some forms of brain
damage that can produce that too.
So anyways,
yeah,
yeah.
So we tested it.
Well,
it turned out that latent inhibition
does look like low latent inhibition.
It looks like it's a importantly related
to creativity and to trade openness.
Abraham Maslow,
he talked about newness of appreciation
as one of the main characteristics of
self actualizing people and I think
that that can be linked to latent
inhibition.
I am sure you would agree.
I bless you just described,
you know,
kind of everything is you
kind of wander to the world.
There's a wonder everything
is kind of fresh again.
Yeah.
The cost is likely.
Something like cognitive overload.
One of the things does,
Shelly Carson and I,
we're trying to investigate
when we studied the hi
openness people at Harvard to
high openness students,
which was very good place to study.
That was that.
It looks like in order to handle the
excess sensory input of low latent
inhibition,
it's really useful to have very high,
well probably high Iq,
but an high working memory.
Those two concepts are quite overlapping,
so it's difficult to
distinguish between them,
but it seems probable that if you're
prone to be overwhelmed by sensory
information that you need the cognitive
capacity to handle that and also perhaps
the,
and we don't know about this yet,
but the personality ability
to sort through that
critically so you don't end up
overwhelmed.
So the shared vulnerability
model of your student,
Shelly Carson is very relevant here,
right?
I don't know.
Do you know about.
I haven't kept up so well in the last
couple of years with the recent work
detailing out the shared
vulnerability models.
Shelly and I wrote a joint series of
articles for the Canadian Journal of
Psychiatry on shared vulnerability
between a openness and predisposition to
schizophrenia.
I mean that's always lurking in the
background when you talk about creativity,
right?
The share the overlap with manic
depressive disorder and potentially with
schizophrenia.
I don't think that's ever
been sorted out properly.
I've written a couple of papers in
the past five years on the genetics of
psychosis and it's
overlapped with creativity,
which is a fascinating,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of recent research on the
genetics of this stuff and showing this
overlap and it seems to be particularly
associate with this openness that things
really opens and things
related to the default network.
So I think the discovery of the default
mode network in recent years has really
allowed us to understand this.
So my colleagues and I published a paper
recently showing a direct link between
the efficiency of the default mode
network and the personality trait.
Openness to experience.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
So we can now link,
we can link,
you know,
the brain structure and network dynamics.
Okay.
So we used a network approach to look at
the connectivity of the default network
and actually analyze
individual differences in the
connectivity between people
within the default network.
So as a measure of your efficiency
within that particular brain network as a
start.
And that was correlated with the
openness to experience domain.
So what does that mean in increased
connectivity within the default network?
Was associated with.
Okay,
and what did the increased
conductivity signify?
What do you think the functional
significance of that is?
I think efficiency in the sense of
quicker information flow between the three
major sub hubs of the default mode
network is the three sub networks that
default mode network involved,
the meaning making meaning making seems
to be a huge part of this network.
You know,
the construction of self.
People who get kind of
this network knocked out,
they don't even know who they are
anymore and I find that fascinating.
And then there's the
mental simulation part,
being able to imagine the future.
That's why I've called this network,
like the imagination network to be sexier
about it because I think default mode
is.
It connotes that it's kind of a passive
network when it's actually a really
active network.
Do you know what I mean?
Like it's not like A.
Yeah,
it does sound like it.
It does make it sound like it's passive.
Hey,
did you see the work done with suicide?
Been showing radical increase in brain
connectivity under the influence of
suicide?
Yeah.
I love that and I think we're on the
verge of something really integrated.
Jordan [inaudible],
like you wrote that paper with
Rachel Aggretsuko Plant and Collin,
you mapped out the whole terrain.
I love that because we've
been building off that.
You could send you a paper where we had
a synthesis of the whole literature.
We have this hierarchical model of the
cognitive exploration domain where you
have like cognitive exploration at the
top and then you have openness and an
intellect,
which is the paper where we showed
openness until like differentially predict
creative achievement,
but then under that you find all sorts
of fastest which contradict which are
negatively correlated with each other.
Even though one step
higher in the hierarchy,
they're positively correlated.
Right?
It seems to be going on there,
right?
Is that there are these breed of humans
that can take these contradictory modes
of thought within themselves.
You know,
most people,
the general population of all these
sorts of the economy is you're either
selfish or you're not selfish.
You're either compassionate or you're not.
You're either,
but it seems like credit people are
amazing at able to like harness these
seemingly contradictory
modes of being and well,
you know,
I,
it's probably a neat process of neoteny,
you know,
I think that the creative
people stay immature.
I love that.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
there's a proclivity in evolution
for creatures to evolve towards there
neotenous forum.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
and it looks to me like
the creative types are,
they're sustaining that plasticity
they have is really early children.
Maybe they are permanently law to some
degree into that pretend play mode.
Okay.
That's so characteristic of children
between the age of four and say,
well maybe 11,
something like that.
Well,
it's good to have both
those things operating,
you know,
because often you talk to people.
This is really characteristic of people
who are sort of on the new age end of
the spectrum.
Carl Jung said something interesting
once about how people think.
He said for most people a thought appears
in their mind and they just accepted
uncritically.
Hmm.
So that's the thinking and.
But that's not really thinking that would
be more associated perhaps with what
you described as activation
of this imagination network,
but it's a lot more difficult to have
the thoughts appear and then to take them
apart and I think it would be really
worthwhile to analyze the role of,
well we know Iq is important in that
obviously because Iq just enables you to
handle a large number of variables.
Hey,
did you find out if that increased
activity that you were describing was
positively associated with Iq?
Okay.
I'm so glad you asked that because I was
going to tell you about the follow up
paper and by the way,
I want to be totally
fair to my collaborators.
This was led by Roger bed.
I ran something with Martin Seligman
the last four years at Penn called the
imagination institute and as
part of that we put out a,
a huge grant for people to do research.
So we funded some of this research
and I was a coauthor and some of these
papers,
but Roger bd did a lot of this work.
Now with that out of the way,
the follow up paper showed that increased
connectivity between the executive
network and the default mode network
was essential for creative thinking,
so openness to experience is not
equivalent to creative thinking.
Right,
so that's the kind of one step is to show
there's a link between the imagination
network,
an openness,
but really real novel and meaningful
creative cognition seem to require that
both the default mode
network and executive network
executive tension and the
salients network.
Actually the salience network
is an interesting network.
We could talk about the interaction
between those two networks were essential
for the cognition to be
novel and meaningful.
That's fascinating because most people
in the general population that santee
correlated,
some of these networks are
anti-correlated like most people.
For most people it's like as soon
as you focus on the outside world,
you shut up your imagination
or when you go home,
imagine.
Yeah,
but creative people who
are really creative,
they're like a good at keeping on call.
That really is interesting
because shelly and I,
back when we were doing the creative
achievement questionnaire research,
we kind of thought that one of the
things that might characterize creative
people is that ability to switch back
and forth between openness and critical
thinking was under voluntary control
suggested.
I think to the extent to which
it's under voluntary control.
I wonder how I could study that.
Like we just know that this is
what the brain networks are doing.
They're toggling back and forth,
but could we ask,
could we do a report?
It's almost with a sense
that like creative people,
as soon as you ask them to think about it,
if they're in the flow state,
then suddenly evaporates.
You know?
It's like,
yeah,
we'll need to.
It's hard to tell how much.
Okay,
so.
Well,
and of course defining
voluntary scientifically is
not a straightforward thing,
but it'd be interesting to see if people
do think about that is voluntary and if
it's a skill as well.
If it's something that people can learn
to develop because you can to some
degree,
teach people critical thinking like you
can teach them to look at an idea and
break it apart and analyze it,
so all that remains to be determined,
I guess.
Hi everyone.
I just wanted to take this moment to
thank you for your support of this podcast
over the years.
It's been a lot of fun doing this
podcast for over the past three years.
If you'd like to further
support the podcast,
I wanted to let you know a few things
you could do to make it a better
experience for you all.
First,
I'd really appreciate it.
If you could subscribe
to the show in itunes.
This will help make the show more
prominent and itunes and increase our
listenership.
I believe you can describe both on
your phone and on your computer.
Second,
it'd be great if you could give the
show a rating and review in itunes.
I definitely read all the reviews.
Another thing you can do is
donate some money to the show,
like under the psychology podcast.com
and clicking on the link support the
podcast at the bottom of the page.
That's the psychology podcast.com.
Some of you had been noting that the
audio quality was less than optimal thanks
to the donations that
we've been receiving.
I'm really excited to announce that in
the next couple of weeks we're gonna have
a completely revamped audio structure
to the show and you should notice a huge
improvement in the audio quality.
Thanks for your patience with that.
Thank you for your support
of the show over the years.
It's been a real labor of love for me.
Okay.
Back to the show.
So let's move onto some other topics.
You did this really
interesting study that I read,
you know I wrote about inside of
America with Christine Brophy on the
personality of credits we
found we were logging well,
two things we wanted to establish.
The first is we wanted to establish if
there was a coherent group of political
beliefs and attitudes.
Let's say that you could bring under
the rubric of political correctness,
you know,
because of course you know that just
because a concept pops up in the popular
literature,
let's say,
or often even in the
psychological literature,
that doesn't mean that
the concept has any basis.
In fact,
what we did was we did a standard
psychometric investigation and so we
oversampled the politically
correct attitude domain.
We had a bunch of people come up with
questions that seemed to be indicative of
what people were describing when they
discuss political correctness in the media
and we put together I think 400 questions
and had a very large number of people
answer all of them and then
subjected the question.
The answer is two,
a factor analysis and came up with a
coherent two factor solution to political
correctness.
One that looked like it was associated
with what you might describe as the
radical left,
the interventionist radical left and
the other that was more associated with,
I would say just left leaning and then
looked at the personality predictors and
personality and cognitive predictors of.
Of both of those,
they weren't.
That highly correlated.
Interestingly enough,
I mean that was partly because we used
to extraction technique that decreased
the correlations,
but you could,
you could extract are two quite separate
sets of political belief and yeah,
trait.
Agreeableness was a good predictor,
which was quite interesting because
it hadn't showed up that power trait,
agreeableness and being female as well,
which was also quite interesting.
We're in a situation now way where it
isn't obvious how men and women are going
to cooperate politically because it does
look like our differences are intrinsic
differences in personality and interest
might divide us quite radically
politically and so god only knows how
that's gonna play out on the political
realm.
Yeah.
It's really interesting
to think about and I.
I've been trying to wrap my head around
the real practical implications when I
look at the data and then try it.
Like I'd like to hear your thoughts on
what you think the percentage of this
could really be impactful.
So like I look at a figure the other day
of the overlap of the distribution and
compassion and there is
in the general population,
we're not talking about like
it's a totally different plan,
you know,
70 percent overlap and the bfs
that you cocreated with Colin,
but,
and so in that paper recalling looked
at the gender differences and the
different big 10 compassion did
have the largest gender difference.
But if you look at the actual graph,
you know,
you see like 70 percent and of course
it doesn't say anything about at the
extremes.
This is something that people
really don't understand.
And social scientists don't
understand that well either.
Although we should.
Like there's two things that were not
trained well I think in social scientists.
One is consideration of the tails because
the tails have disproportionate impact
on behavior and on political
and economic outcomes.
And then the other is the distribution
problem because most of us are taught
that almost everything is normally
distributed and that actually turns out
there's a lot of important
exceptions to that,
including creative achievement.
It's not normally distributed at all.
It's just standard.
Frito distributed probably be small
differences at the average level and then
walloping differences at the extreme
and then it's the differences at the
extreme that determined behavior.
So for example,
no,
there's good evidence that the difference
between men and women with regards to
interest in people versus things
is about one standard deviation,
which is the largest psychometric
difference between the genders.
That's been reported as far as I know.
And so then you think,
well,
okay,
it still means that men and women
overlapped to a large degree.
But if you look at what
determined someone's decision,
for example,
to go into a field like engineering,
you probably have to be.
I wouldn't think what percentage
of the population are engineers.
I bet it's no more than two percent.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
okay,
so let's say one in 50,
maybe it's one in 25,
but whatever.
It's something like that.
Five percent of the population.
So let's say to be an engineer,
well you have to have a high Iq
and you have to be conscientious,
but then you have be interested in things,
but you don't have to be just a
little bit interested in things.
You have to be really interested in
things and even if the okay average
difference between men and women
is only one standard deviation,
which is still a comparatively large,
that could mean that virtually everybody
who's really interested in things ends
up being male and that's
exactly what you see.
You see about a 15 to one preponderance
of male engineers versus female
engineers and you know,
you might say,
well that's socio-cultural and can,
can be ameliorated,
but the evidence doesn't support down at
all because those differences maximize
in the Scandinavian countries.
You mind if I just think
really interesting.
Okay.
And by the way,
I want to thank you for.
I've lost like 100 of your videos
to prepare for this interview.
So like even if I don't
always agree with you,
I,
it helps clarify what in
the hell I actually believe.
So thank you for being so
authentic and your opinions.
I totally believe in
quality of opportunity.
Right?
And it seems like what really irks you
is when people call for equality of
outcome,
that that's really where
you know when you're ready.
Infuriate is a better way.
I know how dangerous it is.
It's unbelievably dangerous.
People have no idea what to messing
with when they mess with equality of
outcome.
Well,
and then do you have a
nuanced discussion about it,
let's say,
because that's what we should do.
It's like,
okay,
the data indicate more and more strongly
that there are significant differences
between men and women in a variety of
dimensions and more importantly that those
differences expand as cultures
become more egalitarian.
Okay,
so then that opens up an
avenue of political questions.
It's like the first
political question would be,
the first observation should be,
we better accept that as fact because
it actually seems to be grounded in very
serious science and the scientists who
discovered this biased in the opposite
direction,
it wasn't what they were happy to find.
No one expected it.
Okay,
but let's take it at face value.
Just for the sake of argument and say,
all right,
now this opens up a minefield
of political questions.
The first is,
so for example,
let me take a pro diversity
stamps just for a minute,
even though it hurts my heart to do so,
so it looks like if we
allowed naturalistic sorting
to take place merely as a
consequence of people's express choices,
that all of the elementary school
teachers would end up being women.
Yeah,
well it's so,
so it's going to be there and it already
is the vast majority of the budget.
If the sorting continues unabated,
that's likely to increase that.
Increasingly it is what it is,
but we don't know what to do about
that from a sociopolitical perspective.
Now you know,
hypothetically we could
enforce equity of outcome,
equality of outcome,
but it would be extremely costly.
It would require a tyrannical effort
on the part of the government and there
would be all sorts of unintended
negative consequences.
Now,
those might be consequences
that we're willing to bear,
but we don't want to move into this
under the presupposition that the
differences.
We're trying to eradicate our only
socio-cultural in nature because clearly
they're not and you'd hope that we
would get to the point where we could
actually have an intelligent
discussion about it.
We don't know what to do about this.
That's the thing,
the proposal,
what to do about it in one of your videos,
the one that I talked about because you
actually made a concrete I and one of
the videos I watched you made
a very specific argument.
You said,
I think that we should eliminate poverty,
that we should have eliminated
unnecessary suffering,
you know,
give everyone a relative
sort of baseline of income.
But then after that is the next stage,
we should sort of allow the free market
to sort of like allow people to then
express.
So you still stand by that.
Will you send that video about
their function of the state?
Well,
I don't know because it's
so complicated like I don't,
I certainly don't think that we should
rush headlong into the provision of a
universal basic income because the
probability that that will have radically
unintended consequences
is unbelievably high.
So I think one of the things
that would probably do,
especially among unemployed,
hopeless people,
is increase their access to
drugs like oxycontin and opiates.
See the problem with the left wing view
of improving economic equality is the
left wingers are so obsessed with the
economic side of inequality that they
don't pay enough attention to
the cultural side of inequality.
So if you're down at the
bottom of the economic pyramid,
the fact that you don't have
enough money is a big problem,
but it's only one of many
serious problems you have.
And I would say an equally serious
problem is that you don't have anything
productive,
engaging and meaningful
to do with your time.
And the problem with that is that,
you know,
I don't know if you know this or not,
but it's pretty easy to get rats that
are isolated in a cage singly to be
addicted to cocaine.
You can do it very rapidly,
but it's almost impossible to get
routes in the naturalistic environment
addicted to cocaine.
That's really interesting.
It is.
Yeah.
Well,
there was there.
He followed just slouched behaviorist
that studied routes in their natural
environment and they're quite a bit
different than the genetically modified
three quarter bodyweight starved single
lab rat existing alone in the cage.
Rats are social creatures,
you know?
Yeah.
Well if you were sitting alone in prison,
yeah,
and somebody and offered you
an endless access to cocaine,
it's like the probability that
you take it is extremely high,
but if you have something
better to do then it's low.
The problem we're going to have to
deal with is more like provision of
meaningful activity to people who
are being displaced by large scale
socioeconomic transformation.
That's not a matter of
merely redistributing income.
Do you know the video I'm talking about
when you talk about the function of the
state?
Yeah.
I think.
I think I would send a political
convention in Canada about five years ago.
I've done work on what are called like.
I've done work on giftedness.
I've been working on kids
with learning disabilities.
Trying to.
The equality of opportunity
is what I'm playing for.
That's what I'm.
And in terms of aligning it
with the science as well,
you know,
it's a beautiful thing me
when they are not a post,
when there's the truth and the
helping someone or you know,
the same thing,
you know,
that's a beautiful thing,
right?
Yeah.
So
this is an interesting question,
is like what could the function of the
state opportunity b too helped her make
sure that there's a quality
of individual expression?
I guess that's what
we're talking about here.
Well that's written.
That is a fundamental question.
I mean million dollar question.
Yeah.
Well one of the things the state does
quite effectively is invest in universally
accessible infrastructure.
So everybody benefits from safe,
clean streets,
right?
And everybody benefits from
it on active cultural meal.
You like a city like Montreal is a really
good example that is extraordinarily
culturally active.
There's festivals going on there all
the time and a lot of them are outside.
A lot of them are free.
Everyone benefits from that.
Education is a good hypothetically,
a good place for the state to invest
with regards to equality of opportunity.
Although it disproportionately benefits
people who are on the upper end of the
cognitive distribution,
it's hard to escape from that a.
So that's for sure.
Back to the back to the
intrinsic difference issue
is like we don't really know
what the political impact is of the fact
that men and women seem highly likely
to sort themselves out into different
occupations if we just allow them free
choice cause no one has thought that no
one thought that was what was going to
happen.
You know when the bloody okay,
radical leftists are fighting this like
mad because they insist that all these
differences are associate cultural,
but the problem is it
doesn't look like they are
all of these politics and fractions,
right?
Individual differences.
What is fits fascinates me.
People are complex systems.
Every one of us is a complex system
of lots of personality traits,
motivations,
etc. And you know,
there are people who score high on
compassion regardless of whether you're a
male or female.
A lot of ice score.
High question I heard you say you score
high on capacity in one of your videos.
You know,
when you went through the bfs,
so it's not like we're saying like,
you know,
you have to be female to be competitive,
which is funny.
With the politically
correct research we did,
we did find that a lot
of the predictive power,
a lot of what was predicting affiliation
with politically correct standpoint was
trait agreeableness,
but being female was an
additional predictor and that
was really strange because
most of the time,
and I'm sure this is the
case with literature that
you've investigated as well.
Most of the time if you look at sex
differences in a particular outcome,
you can get rid of them by
controlling for temperament,
but you could most of them look like
we didn't know there was an additional
effect of there was an additional effect.
Sex.
Yeah.
Did you look at politeness versus
passion?
Yes,
we did,
but I can't.
It's been a while since I reviewed the
paper and I can't bring it to mind.
Okay.
No,
I think it was driven
mostly by compassion,
if I remember correctly.
Yup.
And it makes sense,
you know,
because I think that what's
happening on the end of the spectrum,
let's say political views
are driven by compassion,
is compassion is primarily a dimension
that's there to facilitate intense
relationships between
individuals and their dependents.
Which kind of looks to me like
what compassion does is that,
so you know,
you have compassion for an infant or
you have compassion for someone who's
elderly and unwell.
If you're a very compassionate person,
it's very easy to take the side of the
downtrodden and to look for a perpetrator
or cars and lots of time.
That's extremely useful,
right?
If you're taking care of an infant
and the infant is in distress,
the first thing you should be doing is
scanning the environment for the cause
and eliminating it.
One Answered question is,
well,
what happens when you scale up that
personality attribute and it starts to
operate politically?
Here's some.
Here's the thought for you.
Tell me what you think about this.
I think that we have to traits
that orient us in the social world.
I think agreeable disorients us in small
groups and conscientiousness orients us
in large,
impersonal groups and
that the switch point,
the point where you transitioned from an
agreeable viewpoint to a conscientious
viewpoint is,
is indeterminate.
Is tHere a sex difference on the
conscientiousness are males tire?
No,
you're a little more orderly.
Okay.
And men are a little more into distress.
It does,
yeah.
I was going to ask industrious in
particular because roy baumeister made a
similar.
You could link that to roy baumeister's
argument and what are men good for?
I think that's the title of the book.
He argues that that's
the major sex difference,
that it's not like men or women
are better than each other.
It's that like there have been different
motivations in terms of how we want to
help people and a lot of men have tended
throughout the course of history to
wanting to help,
you know,
like a huge social networks have huge
social networks and I wonder if that's a
difference in exactly what you're saying.
Well,
I think it might be.
I think it might.
Look,
human beings are strange.
First of all,
there's no animal warden
for conscientiousness.
Yeah.
Oh,
is that right?
I've never seen one.
Oh,
that's so interesting.
You know,
it's funny,
I was chatting with column the other day.
He said that,
um,
they just found a correlation between the
salients network and conscientiousness
and that's not really well evolved
in other animals.
That's just interesting.
So look,
if you think about it this way,
if you think that imagine that there's a
human niche niche distinguishes us from
animals and I mean obviously there is,
but one of the distinguishing elements
is that we can produce groups whose size
exceeds that of our
primate cognitive capacity.
So,
you know,
I think it's dunbar's work
indicates that with human beings,
our tribes tend to fractionate when
they exceed about a group of about 200,
but obviously we can produce
groups that are much,
much larger than that that are functional.
But what that means is that those groups
have to operate on principles that are
outside of the networks that other
primates would use to organize themselves
socially.
And I think that's where
conscientiousness kicks in.
Well,
and if you look at what predicts
performance in bureaucracies,
it's conscientiousness,
snot agreeableness.
In fact,
agreeableness is slightly correlated
negatively with managerial performance and
so,
okay.
I think once a group exceeds
the size where it's familiar,
then you have to use a different ethical
system to cope with it and that's
conscientiousness and I think one of
the problems with what's happening to us
politically right now is that
we're trying to implement.
Agreeableness has a political trait and
I don't think it functions well in large
groups.
I hear that argument.
I think sometimes some of the things that
you are perceiving as relevant to the
agreeableness,
to me it might be actually
something different and let
me elaborate what I mean.
So I've done some research lately.
I realized that there's no
scale of pathological altruism.
It's a construct that barbara
oakley has written about,
but I want to do systematic
research on this.
I think this is relevant
to this conversation,
so I constructed a reliable and valid
scale of pathological altruism and it is
negatively correlated with
agreeableness and compassion.
We're not talking about
it's in that domain.
What did you find were the defining
characteristics of pathological altruism?
Okay,
so we looked at grandiose narcissism
versus vulnerable narcissism.
I am so fascinated with that distinction.
I don't think vulnerable narcissism has
got as much attention in the literature.
We found about point six,
point seven,
correlation between pathological
altruism and vulnerable narcissism.
Okay.
Vulnerable narcissism is this,
they called it a psychoanalyst,
got a closet narcism where it's like you
have these grandiose fantasies inside
and you have entitlement,
so you score score skyhigh on entitlement.
However you don't present
yourself that way.
You present yourself as really vulnerable.
We find that the grandiose
narcissism vulnerable,
so they score high on the grandiose
fantasies questionnaIre and entitlement
subscale differentiates them,
is trait neuroticism.
That's the thing that differentiates them,
so whereas grandiose narcissism
is with much lower in neuroticism,
vulnerable narcissism almost perfectly
correlated with high neuroticism,
almost perfectly correlated,
correlated
one of my collaborators who on that paper
he wrote another paper with a title.
Vulnerable narcissism is
mostly just neuroticism.
We're talking about if
you do a structural model,
we're talking literally
almost perfectly correlated.
The only thing that additional variants
that's explained as some antagonism,
like I said,
entitlement for instance,
it's a subset of highly neurotic people
who also have developed a sense of
entitlement,
and assertive,
interpersonal antagonism towards others.
So we're not talking about
you guys are really onto something there.
Great,
great.
Yeah.
I really think so.
I mean the question is whether or not
you're just fleshing out neuroticism with
those sorts of correlations or whether
you've got a subset of people in there
who have taken neuroticism
to the next step.
I don't think it's synonymous with
eroticism because most people who present
themselves with high neuroticism
to the therapist as you know,
if they are depressed,
not like they have this grandiose
fantasy is an entitlement.
Early developmental experiences seems
to be a really interesting moderator.
We found.
We found that those who were told that
they're worthless and childhood or that
were actually in some sense did experience
sort of trauma in their childhood.
That seems to actually
correlate with later on.
And I think that from a
clinician perspective,
you know,
we want to help these individuals
integrate health lena society and I think
maybe that's where your responsibility
argument comes into play.
Well the union idea behind that was the,
those grandiose fantasies
were compensations,
right?
And that within them,
okaY,
there was the seeds in some sense
of the developmental pathway.
So if someone is oppressed and put down
continually and they develop competence,
suntory fantasies,
the fantasies are you can think about
them as the manifestation of that
imagination network,
trying to lay out an
alternative mode of being.
But then those fantasies have to be
subject to critical analysis so they don't
become dwelling places or reasons for
bitterness in relationship to the world.
We just came full circle in the
sense that in a way that started this
discussion,
you know,
like this interplay,
but dynamic interplay between imagination
and then rationality and this.
Well,
the problem with those fantasies,
well the problem with those fantasies
is that they're not decomposed.
Yeah.
So like if you're dealing with someone
that's someone clinically and they have
these fantasies,
then you might think about them as a
starting place for how they could more
modified their life.
so the fantasy is saying the fantasy is
serving as a counterpart to the painful
reality.
The painful reality is downtrodden,
neuroticism.
The fantasy is as far on the other end
of the scale as like it balances the
pathology by putting something on the
other end of the scale that's equally far
away.
Then you have to help the person take a
critical look at the fantasy and start
to make it a reality instead of just a
fantasy and to lay out a strategic plan
for doing that.
Exactly,
exactly.
You know,
I mean look,
we,
we're all human.
Like I personally went through a stage.
I think when I was in my early twenties,
I was so insecure.
Like I wanted it to be like academic.
I wanted to like,
that was my way of proving that I
was smart and that wasn't healthy,
you know,
and like I get it.
But I also get,
you know,
the value of when I really decided to
take some of these grandiose fantasies I
had of being an academic and I say,
well look,
you know,
I'm going to just take it out of my
head and I'm going to like work really
freaking hard.
I mean,
I was in special education as a kid
because I didn't auditory disability.
Yeah.
But I was really young at one point.
I just took 100 percent
responsibility for that situation.
Okay.
So you took the right route out of that.
They'd have those fantasies,
like you can think of those fantasies
as part of the attempt by the,
the mechanism that generates creativity
to lay out a pathway forward.
The problem is,
is when people dwell in,
the founder sees and dwell
on the fantasies instead
of instead of breaking them
down into a strategic
plan and realizing them,
which is what a good therapist
should help someone with.
Absolutely.
I'm sure you've done
that in your practice.
You were in practice over 20 years,
just.
Yep.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also what happens with our future
authoring program because what we really
asked people to do in the future authoring
program is to generate a competence
satori fantasy.
Right now we say,
well,
he lay out how your life could improved
then imagine what your life would be
like if all those improvements took place,
but we don't stop with that.
Okay.
Then we say,
okay,
now subject that to
some critical analysis,
decompose it,
make it into a strategic plan,
break it down into things you would do
day by day and week by week so they can
become realizable in the world.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean that's so sensible,
right?
I mean it's like,
by the way,
this paper I can send to you,
it's actually under review right now.
We have a whole section on the clinical
implications of these findings and
yeah,
I'd like to see it.
Roy baumeister a really
interesting book on.
I think it's the best sort of
real honest assessment of evil.
Have you read the evil inside
human violence and cruelty?
No,
I haven't read it yet.
No.
NoW something.
He talks in there because he wants to get
a full understanding of all the causal
forces of what we call evil and something
in there he talks about is he makes it
so clear that responsibilities
not the same as culpability,
like responsibility at
the same thing as bleeding
the situation you just described,
like let's say that you are
high in neuroticism and you
were subject to bullying
of a real sort and trauma
when you were a kid.
Well,
it's not like you're culpable for that.
Correct?
Correct.
You need to take
responsibility for it because,
well,
who else is going to.
Right,
but you know,
as a scientist and we want to truly,
truly understand the phenomenon.
We need to understand all of the causal
factors and we need to do that as
objectively as possible.
That's not saying that we're
not allowed to have compassion.
Like I have immense compassion want
to make the world a better place.
I know you want to make the
world a better place as well,
but I think I can like kind of separate
those things at different times and then
try to kind of thoughtfully think
through how we can integrate this.
Yeah,
I'd like to see the paper.
I'm very interested in what you're doing.
I'd like to see both of them.
The one on the default network.
Yeah,
and also the one on on
vulnerable narcissism.
I really do think that's associated
with the sorts of things that I've been
talking about.
Relationship to the school
shooters for example,
because they develop grandiose competence,
suntory fantasies,
and then act them out the
most pathological way.
Solely relevant.
Yeah.
Good talking with you.
Good talking to you.
Thanks for your time.
Yep.
And then let me know when this goes
up and I'll tweet it and all of that.
Sounds good.
Have a good day.
Okay.
Okay,
see ya.
Bye.